today if you notice we're all wearing
red why it's national wear red day when
everybody's encouraged to wear red to
bring awareness to women's heart health
cardiovascular disease is the number one
killer of women in this country did you
know that this morning we're looking at
sudden cardiac arrest that means an
abrupt loss of heart function every year
more than 350 000 out of hospital
cardiac arrest occur in this country and
the studies show that women are less
likely than men to receive cpr from a
bystander why and less likely to survive
a cardiac event cbs news senior medical
correspondent that's dr tara narula who
is a cardiologist with northwell health
has the story of one woman who suffered
a sudden cardiac arrest at a very young
age and credit cpr was saving her life
happy birthday to you
celebrating another year of life is
something jenny lynn carpio does not
take for granted
in 2005 she almost died
i was 22 years old when i became a new
mom
i was a new wife and i was a college
student jenny lynn was visiting her
mother jocelyn with her then
two-month-old daughter when she decided
to take a nap and
next thing i remember
my mom frantically
pumping at my chest yelling at me to
wake up
police officer was shining a light in my
eyes and my mom had said that
you just experienced a sudden cardiac
arrest
jocelyn was trained in cpr but she never
expected that she would use it to save
her own daughter's life seeing my
daughter having that thing is kind of
scary
about 90 percent of people who suffer
out of hospital cardiac arrest die but
performing cpr more than doubles
someone's chance of survival at the
hospital doctors discovered jenny lynn
had an undiagnosed genetic heart
condition that can cause irregular heart
rhythms putting her at risk for sudden
cardiac death i was shocked i had to
process
that this was going to be a lifelong
thing
surgeons implanted a defibrillator in
jenny lynn to detect and shock her heart
when abnormal and dangerous heart
rhythms are detected she has now had
four defibrillator replacement surgeries
the most recent in 2020.
with this device jennylin is living a
near normal life and using lessons
learned from her own experience to bring
awareness to sudden cardiac arrest and
the importance of cpr what i would like
other people to know in regards to
sending cardiac arrest
is that it can happen at any time
to anybody and that knowing cpr
is a life-saving skill
and
that is why i'm here today
jenny lynn carpio is now a volunteer
spokeswoman for the american heart
association and she hopes her story will
help encourage others to learn
cpr it's so jarring that it happened to
her at such a young age it is it is and
that's what's so you know you heard the
word sudden cardiac arrest yeah many
times there is not a warning sign and so
it is important to know your risk
factors and your family history but also
to know how to do cpr so you can act in
that moment but are there warning signs
so sometimes there can be and you know
things like chest pain or shortness of
breath lightheadedness passing out or
palpitations you know we in cardiology
always encourage people if you
experience any of these you really need
to pay attention to them don't downplay
them or minimize them and bring them up
to your doctor is cardiac arrest the
same as a heart attack that's a great
question and there's a lot of confusion
around that they are not the same thing
so a heart attack can sometimes trigger
a sudden cardiac arrest
but basically the heart attack means
there's a blockage in an artery that
supplies blood to the heart it's and in
that moment the heart cells can die the
heart muscle dies cardiac arrest is an
electrical problem so essentially the
heart goes into an abnormal or irregular
rhythm and arrhythmia and it's not
pumping so the failure of the heart to
pump means no blood is getting to the
brain getting to the organs you can lose
consciousness and really without
treatment you pretty much will die
within minutes how do you help someone
that's having a cardiac event so this is
the most important question so you know
we try to educate people call 9-1-1 and
start performing cpr it's so easy now to
learn how to do hands-only cpr and
really you can as you heard in the piece
increase someone's chance of survival if
you start bystander cpr before even ems
gets there and also improve their
chances of having a good neurologic
outcome because you start perfusing or
providing blood to the brain and so we
tell people you know push hard and fast
in the center of the chest around 100 to
120 beats per minute
to the song staying alive by the bee
gees in your head that's what you want
to think about a little irony there but
it also works right but why are
bystanders that we said in the lead why
are bystanders less likely to help women
isn't that cpr isn't that a terrible
fact yes so
one of the issues is a lot of times we
think well it's probably not her heart
right if a woman's down on the ground it
must not be heart disease and so that's
one thing another is they are worried
about being inappropriate by touching
her
they're worried that they might hurt her
but really you know three quarters of
these out of hospital arrests are
occurring at home and you know it's so
important to learn this imagine you're
there with your loved one they're on the
ground and you feel helpless but you
don't have to right that's the point of
this segment is to empower people learn
how to do cpr but also if you have
access to a defibrillator this can be
life-saving and they're so easy to use
they walk you through every step you
just push the button it tells you where
to push the pad put the pads and you can
really save someone's life how do you
reduce the risk right so there are risk
factors and this is important to know is
that the majority of patients who have a
sudden cardiac arrest have underlying
structural heart disease most often 70
it's coronary heart disease so coronary
artery disease the other 10 to 15 is
something structurally wrong with the
heart muscle some sort of thickening or
scarring or weakening or something wrong
with the blood vessels and then the last
about 10
are some of these genetic abnormalities
that can trigger arrhythmias like you
heard in the piece with genuine which is
why it's important to know your family
history and to know your risk factors
for heart disease
age was a factor but she was 22. right
so it does increase the incidence of
sudden cardiac arrest increases the
older you get but certainly we see this
as she said in every population every
age both genders all right very good to
see you you look nice and red we've all
got the home right i think it's
important i think it's important to send
this message that we're sending today
leading cause of death for women in this
country
people need to understand that
thank you very much tara to learn more
about how to properly perform the
hands-only cpr and use one of those
portable defibrillators go to our cbs
morning's facebook twitter and instagram
page on cbsmornings.com you can watch
tara there she is a demonstration with
tara and an american heart association
trainer they say anybody can learn to do
this